[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبدا كالمعتاد بالعناوي
تم خلال مباحثاتنا تناول كافه قضايا
العلاقات الثنائيه
تركي مصري في القاهره خطوه نحو التطبيع
الكامل واعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
السعودية تعلن ختامها اكبر تمرين بحري
عسكري 7000 مشارك من خمسين دوله ومنظمه
مصادر للعربيه تكشف عن خمسه او خمسه
ملايين تصريح العمره في رمضان حتى الان
والتوقعات خمسه
ايام على تطبيق نظام سياحه الجديد في
السعوديه ترخيصه الزاميه للانشطه
والاستشارات
خدمه لتوثيق المطاعم التراثيه في السعوديه
هدفها الحفاظ على الهويه وطريقه التقديم
في موضوع التطبيع الكامل مع تركيا اكد
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري في مؤتمر
صحفي جمعه بنظيره التركي مولود شاوشوكلو
في القاهره كشف عن وجود ارضيه صلبه لعوده
العلاقات لطبيعتها بين القاهره وانقر
مضيفا بان هناك توافقا وتنسيقا مستمرا بين
البلدين في عدد من القضايا الاقليميه من
جهته وصف وزير الخارجات التركيه العلاقات
مع مصر بانها تاريخيه ويجب تعزيزها مؤكدا
العمل على تسهيل لقاء يجمع الرئيسين
التركي والمصري قريبا
تم خلال مباحثتنا تناول سيافه قضايا
العلاقات الثنائيه
الاوضاع الاقليميه
التحديات التي نواجهها
وكانت وحدات معمقه
وشفافه وصريحه بحكم
اهميه ما نرغم من اهميه لهذه العلاقات
نحن بالتاكيد ننظر نحو الامام ننظر الى كل
ما يستطيع ان يعود بالنفع على البلدين
خلال المراحل القادمه واثقين من انه
الارضيه الصلبه من ما يربطنا من اواصل
المصاهره
[موسيقى]
التواصل الثقافي هو الذي يعطينا ثقه بانه
هذا المسار سوف يصل الى بشكل قريب وسريع
سوف يصل الى
الغرض والنتيجه المرجوه من كل من البلدين
في اطار
استعاده زخم هذه العلاقات وقوتها
الخارجيه التركيه الى انه بحث مع نظيره
المصري سبل التعاون المشترك في عده قضايا
اقليميه كسوريه والعراق
سوريا
عن بعض القضايا التي تقص سوريا ايراك
وايران
الحدود
وخاصه القضايا الموجوده في الصومال
لقد كان لقائنا حول كل هذا
لابد ان نحسن كل العلاقات على مستوى
المجلس الشعب
مجلس التجاره
ونتمنى بالتاكيد ان تذيب ويعود هذا
على
دولهنا واحب ان نعبر ان هناك استثمارات
قويه جدا
ما بين الدولتين
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى باكستان حيث اندلعت مواجهه عنيفه
بين الشرطه وانصار الرئيس وزراء باكستان
السابق عمران خان قبل مغادرته لاهور وفي
اسلام اباد بعد وصوله وزاره الداخليه
الباكستانيه كشفت انها عثرت على اسلحه في
منزل خان وانا المنطقه التي يسكن فيها
رئيس الوزراء السابق محظور وقد تم
التطهيرها حسب تعبير الشرطه رئيس وزراء
باكستان شهباز شريف قال من جهته ان عمران
خان استغل انصاره كدروع وان مواقفه في
الفتره الاخيره اصبحت غريبه حزب الذي
يتزعمه عمران خان اتهم شرطه الباكستانيه
باستهداف سياره رئيس الوزراء السابق لمنع
وصوله الى المحكمه مراسل العربيه كان افاد
قبل ذلك بان الشرطه الباكستانيه اعتقلت
عددا من انصاره عمران خان في اسلام اباد
فضلا عن قيامها بحمله امنيه على مقره في
لا هور
[موسيقى]
نتابع معكم الان هذه الصور الان التي
وصلتنا وصول الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
الى جزيره القرم في الذكرى التاسعه لضم
الجزيره الى روسيا من المتوقع ان يلقي
رئيس الروسي فلاديميل بوتين خطابا في
اثناء هذه الزياره للجزيره ربما يتحدث
فيها عن مسار العمليه العسكريه الخاصه كما
تصفها موسكو في اوكرانيا اضافه الى
التطورات الاوضاع الاخرى في جزيره القرم
تحديدا
في تداعيات الحرب الاوكرانيه وفيما يبدو
محاوله من الرئيس الروسي لوقف التناسلي
بين الدفاع الروسيه ومجموعه وقع فلاديمير
بوتين مرسوما يقضي بغرامات ماليه وعقوبات
تصل الى سجن 15 عاما لمنتقدي الجيش
والمتطوعين بما في ذلك قوه الخاصه وكان
مجلس الدوما وافق على القانون الذي يتضمن
عقوبات سجن قاسيه بحق منتقدي المشاركين في
العمليات العسكريه باوكرانيا حتى وهو
اجراء كان ينطبق في السابق على الجيش
النظامي فقط فالمقابل كان قائد
دعا الى السماح للروس انتقاد كبار القاده
العسكريه
مذكرات التوقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين من قبل المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه قد تعد ايضا مجرد خطوه في طريق
طويل حتى يقدم للمحاكمه لكنها قد تحد ايضا
من تحركاته
يمكن اعتقال الرئيس بوتين فعلا بعد تعميم
المذكره على الدول الاعضاء في المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
الدول التي ليست عضوا بالمحكمه غير ملزمه
بقراراتها لكن يحق لنا الطلب من اي دوله
عضو اعتقال بوتين
تحركات الرئيس بوتين باتت محدوده بسبب
العقوبات الجديده منذ الهجوم الروسي على
اوكرانيا سافر بوتين الى ثماني دول منها
سبع كانت ضمن الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
بوتين لن يغامر بالسفر الى اي دوله ترغب
في تقديمه الى المحكمه الجنائيه الا ان
زيارته الى حلفائه الاقليميين في الصين
وايران لم تشكل خطرا عليه كما انه لن
يواجه اي خطر داخل روسيا كونه يتمتع
بالسلطه المطلقه
رحب المستشار الالماني بقرار المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه اصدار مذكره التوقيف بحق
الرئيس روسي فلاديمير بوتين مشددا على ان
مذكره التوقيف بوتين تظهر ان لا احد فوق
القانون الدولي
ليس لدي الكثير لاضيفه لا احد فوق القانون
هذه
ركيزه مهمه للغايه من اركان القانون
الدولي نعلم جميعا ان المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه مؤسسه مهمه منحت ولايتها من خلال
المعاهدات الدوليه
في الرابع بعد قليل وكاله مودز لخدمه
المستثمرين تعدل النظره المستقبليه
للسعوديه من مستقره الى ايجابيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اقتتمت القوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه فعاليات التمرين البحريه
الدوليه المختلط متعدد الجنسيات اي ام اكس
23 سي اي الذي يعد من الاكبر عالميا وقيمه
نسخته الاخيره بمشاركه 7000 مشارك من اكثر
من 50 دوله ومنظمه اقليميه ودوليه فضلا عن
30 منظومه ذكاء اصطناعي ومنظومات غير
ماهوله وخمس وثلاثين قطعه بحريه وشمل
التمرين سيناريوهات بحريه في مناطق عمليات
بالخليج العربي وبحر عمان وشمال بحر العرب
والمحيط الهندي وخليج عدن والبحر الاحمر
لتعزيز الامن البحري في المنطقه
اختتمت القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه
فعاليات التمرين البحري الدولي المختلط
متعدد الجنسيات
ويعد التمرين من اكبر التمارين البحريه
المختلطه في العالم والذي شاركت قواتنا
البحريه بمملكه البحرين الشقيقه والمملكه
الاردنيه الهاشميه الشقيقه وقد نفذت
العديد من الفرضيات بكل احترافيه من قبل
قواتنا مشاركه حيث تم تحقيق جميع الاهداف
المجادوله والمخطط لها مسبقا
الجدير بالذكر ان هذا التمرين تم بمشاركه
اكثر من خمسين دوله ومنظمه دوليه و30
منظومه ذكاء صناعي ومنظمات غير ماهوله
وخمسه وثلاثين قطعه بحريه بمجموع 7000
مشارك وتشمل مناطق عمليات التمرين مياه
الخليج العربي وبحر عمان وشمال البحر
العرب
عدلت وكاله مودز لخدمه المستثمرين النظره
المستقبليه للسعوديه من مستقره الى
ايجابيه كما اكدت تصنيفها في الفئه
واحد ويعكس تغيير النظره المستقبليه الى
ايجابيه احتمالا انخفاض اعتماد السعوديه
الاقتصادي والماليه على قطاع
الهيدروكربونات وذلك من خلال الاستثمارات
في قطاعات غير نفطيه مختلفه مما يؤدي الى
تخفيف تعرضها لمخاطر دورات اسعار النفط
وكما يعكس تاكيد التصنيفات في الفئه اي
واحد الابقاء على مستوى دين المعتدل وهو
اقل من دين غالبيه الجهات السياديه ذات
التصنيف المماثل لها
نعود الى متابعه موضوع زيارات وزير
الخارجات تركي الى القاهره
ولقائه بوزير الخارجيه المصري واثر ذلك
على العلاقات بين البلدين ينضم الينا من
واشنطن حمدي صالح مساعد وزير الخارجيه
المصري الاسبق سيد حمدي اهلا وسهلا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه
هلا اصبحت تطبيع الكامل بين البلدين قريبا
يعني
الانتقال من حاله الانهيار الكامل التي
شهدتها هذه العلاقات بسبب هذه الزياره
التي قام بها وزير الخارجيه التركيه الى
مصر
وتطورات فيها وبذا سيحدث في المستقبل
القريب وطبعا مصر ملتزمه التزاما كاملا
بايه
الحفاظ على الاراضي السوريه ووحده الاراضي
السوريه وده احد القضايا المعلقه التي لم
يتحدث عنها
حتى في اللقاءات بيتكلموا عليها في موسكو
ايضا هناك القضيه الخطيره
المؤثره جدا على العلاقات المصريه التركيه
وهي ليبيا ماذا سيحدث في ليبيا قضايا
التدخل التركي في الغرب الليبي
وبالتالي ماذا يمكن ان اقول وزير الخارجيه
في هذه الفتره ده نقطه مهمه ولكن يبقى
ايضا القضيه الكثيره الكبيره الاقليميه
وهي غاز شرق البحر المتوسط
في هذه المشكله ربما مثل تستطيع ان تقوم
بدور الوسيط مصر استطاعت ان تكون متوازنه
في علاقتها ما بين تركيا واليونان وتركيا
والدول الاخرى لماذا طويل ويمكن ان تعود
هذه الى نقطه التوازن دي ولكن لكي يكون
هناك نقطه توازن يجب ان ارتبطت دكتور سيد
يعني بمساله التغيرات التي نشهدها اليوم
في العالم هذه التغيرات يمكن ان تتخذ شكل
الحاله من الاستقطاب الحدث بالتالي ما
يحدث الان هل هو هل هو يعني
ذهاب حقيقي نحو حل مسائل خلافيه شائكه
وخطيره كما ذكرتها ام تهدئ فقط يعني
التغير في الديناميكيات وتحركات البلدين
دون يعني ربما الوصول الى نتائج حقيقيه في
مسار هذه الملفات
والله على السؤال مهم جدا ليس هناك اجابه
عليه الا سنرى مع الايام يعني
لحد دلوقتي منفتحه على التعامل مع مصر
وعلى تقليل التوتر ولكن الى اي مدى
ملتزمه بتقليل التوتر وبحل هذه المشاكل
اتكلمنا عليها ليبيا وسوريا
المتوسط يعني لحد دلوقتي ليس واضحا هناك
نيه ولكن هذه النيه يجب ان يكون موضع
التفاوض معمق لحل هذه المشاكل ولكن ايضا
زي ما اشرت المنطقه كلها داخله على مرحله
جديده يعني
انفتاح السعودي على على التصرف مع ايران
وايضا الموقف الخليجي بصرف عام بصفه عامه
ان لا يكون هناك حرب وما اليه كل ده بيمثل
تطور مهم اقليمي يجب ان يؤخذ في الاعتبار
في طبيعه العلاقات بين دولتين اساسيتين في
المنطقه وتركيا ولكن ما زال هناك في ملف
ليبيا على سبيل المثال حتى الان لا توجد
اي مؤشرات على تغير حقيقي في سياسه او
الاستراتيجيه التركيه في في ليبيا تركيا
كما يقال على حسب الكثير من التقارير ربما
هدات مؤخرا لكن ما زالت تستمر في دعمها
وتدريباتها العسكريه
مرتزقه والميليشيات الموجودين او الموجوده
هناك معظم المصالح الاستراتيجيه ايضا
التركيه التي تريد المحافظه عليها من نفوذ
اقتصادي من نفوذ امني لا زالت تمثل ايضا
حقائق واهداف استراتيجيه حقيقيه في تركيا
مصر الى اين يمكن ان تذهب في هذا الملف
في مقابل انقره يعني في هذه النقطه في هذا
نقطه التحول انا لا اريد ان اضيف يعني
حساسيه اكثر
بين تركيا ومصر بالتاكيد هناك مشاكل عميقه
واختلافات عميقه بخصوصا الغربي
وموقف غرب الليبي مرتبط ايضا بموقفهم
الاخوان المسلمين والتجمعات الاسلاميه ما
زال هذا الملف عالقا وموضع نقاش بين
الدولتين طبعا القضيه الاساسيه التي
المحوريه هي انها تريد ان تتطور علاقتها
مع العالم العربي ومسك الدوله الرئيسيه
ولكن دون ان تخسر النقاط الاستراتيجيه
التي كسبتها في الفتره السابقه سواء في
ليبيا في سوريا وده مش مش هيكون يعني
انفتاحا كاملا لتحسين العلاقات ولكن على
الاقل هناك بدايه هذه البدايه بزياره
الخارجيه
العلاقات الاقليميه بعد ايران
مع السعوديه جيد يعني يقدم صوره مختلفه
للموقف الدولي وبالتالي يجب ان تركيا ان
تاخذ هذا في موضوع خلافات شرق البحر
المتوسط علاقات انقره مع اليونان وقبرص
يعني ايضا مصر كيف يمكن ان تذهب هل
المساله مساله بساطه لكن ماذا لو كان هناك
ايضا رغبه تركيه او ضغط تركي في محاوله
تغيير القاهره
لتحالفاتها بشكل جدري لصالح انقره نوعا ما
هل يمكن ان يحدث ذلك
يعني بالتاكيد هناك رغبه تركيه بالافراح
على مصر وان يكون هناك علاقه وديه
والنقطه الاساسيه
انه لا يكون هذا على حساب علاقاتها
ولكن هذه النقطه التوازن دي التي يجب ان
تستمر عليها المصريه نقطه صعبه وخصوصا
تركيا ما زالت يعني بتطالب غير مقبوله من
الجانب اليونان
راحل حاليا هو هناك احتمال قوي تقوم مصر
بهذه الوساطه
الجانبين
ويعني غاز الشرق المتوسط هي مهمه وملحه
وبالتالي اذا تتحدث عن انه يجب ان يكون
هناك يعني توزيع عادي وهذا وهذا
الاستراتيجيه المصريه
ولكن هذا التوزيع يجب ان يكون وفقا
لمفاوضات مباشره ما بين تركيا ولبنان
والحرس ومصر ستكون الدور الوسيط في هذا
ولكن زي ما اشرت في قضيه معقده ليست قضيه
سهله
بمعنى اخر زياره وزير الخارجيه الحالي
حاليا هي انفتاح بدايه الطريق لحل هذه
القضايا او المفاوضات المعلقه حول هذه
الخط
ايا ستاخذ وقتا يعني ستاخذ كذلك ربما
محادثات مستمره في هذه المحادثات من الذي
سيلعب الدوري الاكبر وانت يعني
علاقتك مع الدبلوماسيه علاقه عريقه في هذه
المحادثه والمناقشات الذي سيلعب الدوري
الاكبر فيها هل هم ممثلون خارجيه
والدبلوماسيه ام اجهزه المخابرات والامن
بين البلدين وهل يمكن ان تتفق فعليا هذه
الاجهزه اذا كان الامر بهذا الشكل في
مساحه تلتقي فيها كل الاطراف في هذه
الملفات المعقده المتشابكه لتحقيق مصالح
البلدين اما ذلك يعني ربما غير وارد او
غير محتمل او قد ياخذ وقتا طويلا
[موسيقى]
وسيكون هناك نقاش ولكن بالتاكيد تتطور هذه
الرؤيه مع الاخذ والعطاء والمفاوضات
المباشره وغير مباشره تقوم بها مصر مع
ولكن في النهايه تركيا بتواجه موقف اقليمي
وعليها ان تاخذ هذا في الاعتبار واعتقد ان
هذه السياره تمثل يعني نقطه انفتاح ونقطه
في الاعتبار ان الرئيس الرئيسي يدخل في
انتخابات في فتره قصيره وبالتالي يعني
يهتم جدا ان يكون علاقتهم مع الدول
العربيه وخصوصا الدول الرئيسيه مصر
والسعوديه والخبيرات علاقه طيبه لانها زي
انه يعني سينعكس انعكاسا على الوضع
الاقتصادي والعكس ايضا على يعني الوضع
العام بالراي العام
كذلك بمصر ربما تعان تعاني او تواجه واقعا
مختلفا وقعا صعبا ربما خاصه من النواحي
الاقتصاديه سيد حمدي فبالتالي هل يمكن ان
يكون هذا السبب دافعا لمصر في التنازل
بالرضا بامر واقع ربما يفرضه او مفروض
الان في مقابل الحصول على مكاسب اقتصاديه
في الملفات التي تحدثت عنها
والله ليس هناك احتمالات لمكاس اقتصاديه
مع تركيا
يعني
[موسيقى]
يكون هناك علاقات وديه مع الدوله التركيه
مع الشعب التركي
والا لن نستطيع ان نعيش في امان وبالتالي
هناك رغبه مصريه في الانفتاح ولكن لا
اعتقد ان الضغوط الداخليه الاقتصاديه تؤثر
على القرار المصري بالنسبه
ولكن بالاصل العناصر الاساسي ان الموقف
الاقليم يتغير ماذا سيكون موقفنا احنا
كمصر وموقف تركيا
وماذا سيحدث في المستقبل وهل اسرائيل
ستساكم نقطه
المفسد في الوضع ما يسمى انها تعمل عنيف
كل دي محتاجه الى الى دراسه واعاده تنظيم
وعد د الاستراتيجيه
المتحده وبالتالي تستطيع ان ترى من
الجانبي شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن حمدي
صالح مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصري الاسبق
كشفت مصادر العربيه عن بلوغ تصريحات حجوز
تطبيق نسك للعمره حاجز المليون تصريح خلال
شهر رمضان القادم ياتي ذلك في وقت اعلنت
فيه الجهه المعنيه في مكه المكرمه عن
اكتمال استعدادات لاستيعاب المعتمرين
القادمين من خارج المملكه وداخلها وسط
توقعات ايضا بعوده الارقام الى ما قبل
جائحه كورونا للتجاوز الخمسه ملايين معتمر
خلال شهر رمضان
الحرم المكي انضم الينا مراسل العربيه
السلطان السلمي سلطان مرحبا بك
كيف تصف لنا صوره لعند الحرم المكي الشريف
وسط هذه المعلومات التي تتحدث عن اعداد
كبيره من تصريحات المعتمرين
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه عملت منذ وقت السابق وساره الحج
والعمره السعوديه وكذلك رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين وايضا القطاعات الامنيه العامله
هنا في العاصمه المقدسه والتحديدا في
الحرم المكي للتعامل مع اعداد مليونيه سوف
يشهدها الحرم المكي طوال ايام الشهر رمضان
نتحدث على ايام قليله تفصلنا عن شهر رمضان
لذلك نشاهد اعداد كبيره من المعتمرين
والموصلين توافدون بشكل يومي هنا في الحرم
المكي لذلك نتحدث على اكثر من مليون شخص
او تحديدا من قديم من اوروبا وامريكا
واستراليا حجزوا لهذا الموسم للعمره في
موسم رمضان عبر تطبيق نسك نتحدث عن اعداد
مليونيه رئاسه شؤون الحرمين والجهات
العامله سوف يستقبلوا الحرم المكي طوال
شهر رمضان اذا ضربنا مثال بسيط نتحدث على
صحن المطاف الذي يتشكل من الدور الارضي
والاول والثاني وكذلك الاسطح نتحدث على
مئه وسبعه الاف او طائف في الساعه الواحده
يستوعبها تحدثنا على 24 ساعه نتحدث على
رقم يتجاوز اثنين مليون ونصف المليون
معتمر في اليوم الواحد نتحدث كذلك عن
تفعيل
الساحات او التوسعات السعوديه الثلاث في
الحرم المكي لاستقبال كافه المعتمرين
وكذلك المصلين ايضا من المتوقع كذلك ان
يشهد التطبيقات الخاصه بحجز العمره في شهر
رمضان ازدحام كبير مما جعل القطاع لوزاره
الحج والعمره بتكثيف الادوار او الكوادر
البشريه والاجهزه والامكانيات والذكاء
الاصطناعي لاستقبال اكبر عدد ممكن من
المعتمرين في شهر رمضان بعد تفعيل الطاقه
الاستيعابيه الكامله للحرم المكي نتحدث
على ادوار الداخليه والاسطح وكذلك
التوسعات اذا تحدثت على سبيل المثال
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه تستوعب اكثر من
600 الف مصلي في اليوم الواحد وهذه
التوسعه خذ خصصت لاداء الصلوات في رمضان
فيما يتعلق بصحن المط الادوار الثلاث تم
تخصيصها للمعتمر وذلك كنوع من تنظيم
العمليه لدخول وخروج المعتمرين والمصلين
بشكل مريح جدا ونتحدث عن 14 بوابه للدخول
الخروج في الحرم المكي تم تخصيصها
لمعتمرين فقط ايضا نتحدث على مسارات خاصه
سوف يتم تخصيصها للمشاه وهي للطرق
المقابله او المجاوره للحرم المكي لتسهيل
عمليات دخول المعتمرين داخل الحرم المكي
طوال شهر رمضان ايضا تكثيف اعداد العاملين
لتصل الى 12 الف عامل يعملون في اليوم
الواحد هنا في الحرم المكي ايضا تحدث عن
ثمانيه الاف متطور سوف يعملون في الحرم
المكي لتقديم كافه الخدمات التطوعيه
للمعتمرين خطط مختلفه تم تكثيفها تم تزويد
اعداد العاملين تم تهيئه كافه الخدمات
والبنيه التحتيه للتعامل مع الاعداد
المليونيه المتوقعه التي كان الحرم المكي
يشهدها في مواسم رمضان قبل بدء ونهايه ج
لذلك نشاهد استعدادات كبيره وكذلك اعداد
ايضا بدات تتوافد الى الحرم المكي مع قرب
شهر رمضان لاداء لاداء العمره لذلك شاهد
كثافه كبيره داخل صحن المطاف وكذلك
الادوار الداخليه للحرم المكي وايضا تم
تفعيل الدور الاول ولم يتم تفعيلها نظرا
لعدم يعني حاجه ذلك ايضا نتحدث على خدمات
كبيره وادوار كبيره تعمل عليها القطاعات
الامنيه لتنظيم عمليات الدخول هذه السنه
لذلك من المتوقع ان يوم الثلاثاء القادم
هنالك اجتماع لقيادات قوات امن العمره
لوضع الخطط واعلان الخطط التشغيليه لموسم
رمضان هذا العام لكيفيه دخول وخروج
المعتمرين وكيفيه تنظيم المسارات وكذلك
تفعيل كافه الطرق المواصلات نتحدث على
الحرمين وايضا كذلك حافلات مكه التي سوف
تعمل بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه هذا العام
لايصال المعتمرين والمصلين الى حرم
المكينا لك من الحرم المكي الشريف مراسل
العربيه السلطان السلم
في الرابعه بعد الفاصل
ثمانيه ايام على تطبيق نظام السياحه
الجديد في السعوديه رخيصه الزاميه للانشطه
والاستشارات
تم خلال مباحثاتنا تناول كافه قضايا
العلاقات الثنائيه
المصريه في القاهره خطوه نحو التطبيع
الكامل واعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
السعوديه تعلن الختامها اكبر تمرين بحريا
عسكري 7000 مشارك من خمسين دوله ومنظمه
خمس او مصادر العربيه تكشف عن مليون تصريح
للعمره في رمضان حتى الان والتوقعات خمسه
وضعه
ثمانيه ايام على بدء تطبيق نظام السياحه
الجديد في السعوديه ترخيص الزاميه للانشطه
والاستشاره
وخدمه لتوثيق المطاعم التراثيه في
السعوديه حفاظ على الهويه والطريقه
التقديم
ثمانيه ايام فقط تبقت على تطبيق نظام
السياحه الجديد في السعوديه الذي يدخل حيز
التنفيذ في 25 من الشهر الخالي بهدفه
تطوير القطاع وتوفير بيئه جاذبه للاستثمار
وكانت وزاره السياحه اصدرت النظام الذي
يضم عشره لوائح جديده تشمل مجالات منها
مرافق الضيافه وخدمات السفر والسياحه
والارشاد السياحي مشيره الى ان اللوائح تم
اعدادها وفقا لافضل الممارسات العالميه
بهدف بناء قطاع سياحي منافس عالميا
نظام السياحه الجديد في السعوديه يضم
لوائح محدثه وملزمه لعمل مرافق الضيافه
والانشطه الاخرى من خدمات السفر والسياحه
والارشاد السياحي
يبدا التطبيق الالزامي للنظام والحصول على
الترخيص في 25 من مارس الحالي اذا ظهر ان
المرفق السياحي يشكل خطرا على الصحه او
السلامه العامه تتخذ اجراءات منها الاغلاق
واذا كان مخالفا فسيتعرض لدفع غرامه لا
تزيد عن مليون ريال لوائح النظام شملت
المخيمات ضمن المرافق السياحيه للمره
الاولى وحددتها بثلاثه تصنيفات هي 45 نجوم
كما اكد النظام على ضروره الحصول على
ترخيص لمزاوله نشاط الاستشارات السياحيه
سواء للافراد او المكاتب كما كشف النظام
انه في حال تعذر تقديم الخدمه المتفق
عليها يخير السائح بين توفير خدمه بديله
مساويه للاولى او استرجاع كامل ما دفع له
حدد النظام نوعين للتاشيره بغرض السياحه
الاولى الدخول لمره واحده وصلاحيتها ثلاثه
اشهر والثانيه تاشيره دخول متعدد
وصلاحيتها سنه
[موسيقى]
في استديوهاتنا من الرياض المختص في
قطاعات السياحه والضيافه ثامر الحربي
سيتامر حياك الله معك اهلا وسهلا
تشرفت على تطبيق النظام السياسي الجديد لو
عدنا لتذكر ابرز مميزات هذا النظام فيه
وما الجديد يعني وكيف يمكن توقع مستقبل
السياحه في المملكه بعد تطبيق طبعا تطبيق
النظام السياحي جديد راح يعمل عمله انه
نقل نوعيه في خدمات السياحه المقدمه من
ناحيه الجوده من حيزات المعروضه السياحي
كذلك في تعزيز البيئه الاستثماريه سياحيه
في المملكه اليوم عندنا طموح كبير جدا في
قطاع السياحه فبالتالي لمواكبه هذا الطموح
والتغير ليس فقط في المملكه وفي الاقليم
حتى على مستوى العالم حتى النظام السياحه
الجديد مواءمه هذا التغيير الحاصل سواء في
مرافق الضيافه السياحيه المقدمه او حتى في
خدمات السياحه اليوم نعرف ان السياحه اصبح
عنده وعي اكبر اصبح عنده يعني تخيل اوسع
بالتالي نحتاج ان نواكب هذا التغيير لدى
السائح من تقديم ماده جوده عاليه تجربه او
انشطه تجريبيه جديده في المملكه تواكب مع
تغير او تواكل مع الطبيعه الثقافيه
والطبيعيه اللي موجوده في مناطق السياحيه
في المملكه بالتالي كيف راح يتغير ممكن
نقول مستقبل قطاع السياحه عندنا احنا
متفائلين بشكل كبير جدا في التغيير اللي
راح يحصل في قطاع السياحي اولا من ناحيه
جوده الخدمات السياحيه المقدمه نستهدف ان
نرفع من جوده الخدمات السياحيه المقدمه
بالشكل اللي يضمن ليس فقط رضا سحب حتى
تكرار لزياره السياحيه داخل المملكه واحد
اثنين عمليه تعزيز التنافسيه في البيئه
الاستثماريه السياحيه في المملكه اليوم
نعرف راح يدخل يعني علامات تجاريه كبرى من
خارج المملكه وكذلك من داخل المملكه
فبالتالي تعزيز 100 الاستثماره تكون بيئه
عادله وامنه واركز اخوي خالد انها تكون
مرنه فاحنا اليوم حنا في مستثمرين موجودين
في القطاع السياحي وفي مستثمرين جدد راح
يدخلون في القطاع السياحي ومستقبلا
فبالتالي احنا نحتاج الى نوائ هذا التغيير
اللي موجود وفقا لنظام السياحه الجديد
ثلاثه نرفع في عمليه تعزيز الوعي ليس فقط
عن خدمات السياحيه بل حتى على المواقع
السياحيه اللي موجوده نحن من سمعه تلك
المواقع نحافظ عليها تكون مستدامه اليوم
حنا لا نستهدف فقط ان ننجح خلال فتره
قصيرنا كلنا هذا مستمر ومستدام في وجهاتنا
السياحيه الجميله داخل المملكه تكاليف
تراخيص حتى العقوبات البعض يتحدث بانها قد
تكون
منفره اكثر من ان تكون مرغبه بالتالي
المشهد ربما
يشير الى خروج فئه كبيره ربما من المهتمين
بهذا القطاع واللي كان عندهم
بعض العقارات ربما او الاشياء اللي ممكن
كانوا يستفيدوا منها خلال الفتره السابقه
ما رايك طبعا التغيير موجود ولابد ان
نواكب هذا التغيير كل مستثمره ومستثمره
بالقطاع الساحلي لابد انه يراعي ويعيد
دراسات اللي موجوده حتى يواكب هذا التغيير
ليس فقط النجاح قطاع السياحه في المملكه
حتى على مستوى المشاريع المعايير اللي
وضعت وضعت معايير مرنه حتى يعني الكواكب
هذا التغيير اللي موجود حتى تنجح تلك
المشاريع اللي موجوده اليوم اخوي خالد
اسمح لي نعرف ان المنشات اللي موجوده في
القطاع الساحلي ليس فقط في المملكه حتى
على مستوى العالم 80% منها من المشاريع
الصغيره والمتوسطه فبالتالي نحتاج لنرفع
عند الوعي عند رواد الاعمال الناس اللي
يقدمون الخدمات السياحيه لفضل على سبيل
المثال اليوم لاول مره في تاريخ المملكه
وقره لائحه وفق النظام السياحه جديد لائحه
مرافق الضيافه السياحيه الخاصه انه اصحاب
العقارات اصحاب المنازل يقدرون هم يشاركون
ساعه تجربته ويثرون تجربه هذا السحب
وبالتالي حنا هذه فرصه ليس فقط للمجتمعات
المحليه حتى للقطاعات التجاريه انها تبدا
ان تفكر في عمل تقديم خدمه ابداعيه ثريه
للسياحه اللي موجود عندنا حتى ننجح في
ابهار هذا السائح وفي تجربه في شروط مشدده
استاذ محمد تامر عفوا طبعا يعني مثلا انه
والله شقه لابد يكون لها موقف خاص اس
بالاضافه الى مدخل واحد البعض يقول انه
هذه شروط مشدده يعني الشروط اللي وضعت
راعي احتياج ونظره الساحل اللي موجود طبعا
ليست بالمستحيله انا اعتقد انه الكثير
يقدرون يطبقون هذه الشروط والمعايره اللي
موجوده هذه من ناحيه المعايير اللزاميه مع
العلم وفي وجود معايير غير الزاميه
واختياريه من خلال جمع النقاط لكن هذه
المعايير حين راعي فيها نظره السائح
للسائح يحتاج انه يكون لها الخصوصيه
الاكثر يحتاج انه يحصل على جوده اعلى
يحتاج انه يحصل على حقه كامل فحنا اليوم
ليس فقط حتى نحميه سياحه اليوم حتى احنا
نراعي في العمليه التجاريه اللي موجوده في
قطاعات السياحه انها يعني تكون ناجحه
تجاريه لان احنا نجاح والتجاري يعني
النجاح القطاع بشكل عام طبعا ربما بعض
رواد الاعمال او المستثمرين يواجهون بعض
المشاكل لذلك كانت في فتره 90 يوم اللي
راح تنتهي بعد ثمان ايام اعتقد ان الكثير
يعني راعي هذا الفتره انه يغير من وضعه
انه يحسن من الخدمه اللي يحاول قدر
الامكان انه يلتزم فيها الاسعار في السكن
في غيرها من الامور ترفع بتنزل بتبقي على
دائما واعتقد انه في كثير من الناس تقول
انه الاسعار عاريه جدا في الفنادق في
غيرها من الاماكن السياحيه فبالتالي هل
يتوقع التغيير قادم انا متفائل ان شاء
الله راح تكون في اسعار
يمكن في البدايه راح يكون في عمليه رفع في
الاسعار لانه راح يقل المعروض السياحه
اللي موجود لكن المستقبل مختلف تماما راح
يكون عندنا معروض يعني افضل جوده افضل راح
تكون في تنافسيه اعلى راح يكون في وعي لدى
المستثمر السياحي بكل تاكيد المستقبل
مختلف بشكل مبهر شكرا يعطيك العافيه يا
سامر الحربي المتخصص في قطاعه السياحه
والسفر شرفت معكم اخي خالد
خدمه تسجيل المطاعم التراثيه في السعوديه
تاتي في اطار التجويد المطبخ المحلي من
خلال الطرق الطهي وتقديم الاكلات الشعبيه
مما يساهم في جعل المطاعم التراثيه وجهه
سياحيه للتعرف على الثقافه المحليه وخلق
فرص عمل للطهار السعوديين عالي اللغبي
الاهتمام بالمطاعم التراثيه لا يقتصر على
ابراز الهويه المحليه بل يمتد الى تطوير
الاطباق الشعبيه تماما كما هو الحال في
مطاعم الاحساء التراثيه والتي تحتفظ
بهويتها من خلال اكلاتها الشعبيه وطرق
تقديمها حرصنا ان نقدم الاطباق الشعبيه
المرتبطه بالمنطقه الاحساء بايادي طباخات
سعوديات
الاطباق اللي احنا نقدمها للاطباق الشعبيه
اللي مرتبطه بالمنطقه عامه مثل العيش
الحساوي والهريس الحساوي والمثلج وعندنا
الكبسه الحسويه والجريش الحساوي
والاطريقه التقديم حنا نقدمها بالطريقه
التقليديه باطباق تكون تقليديه تخص تراث
المنطقه عامه تضيف للمطاعم التراثيه في
السعوديه قيمه مضافه لاسيه ما في القطاع
السياحي من خلال تعدد اطباقها الشعبيه
التي تبرز تنوع المحليه لتشكل وجهه
للمهتمين في التعرف على المطبخ السعودي
بالنسبه لخدمه تسجيل المطاعم التراثيه
السعوديه فهي تساعد على تطوير المطبخ
السعودي وتساعد على تطوير الاكلات
السعوديه التراثيه
برضو تبرزها عالميا
وتوفر فرص عمل للشابات السعوديات في طريقه
التقديم وطريقه الطهي خدمه تسجيل المطاعم
التراثيه التي اطلقتها هيئه فنون الطهي
تتضمن تصنيفها بحسبه منصه التراخيص
الثقافيه ابدع اما مطعما سعوديا اصيلا او
مطعم ذوق سعودي وذلك وفق الاليات وضوابط
والاشتراطات في تصنيف المطاعم والاطباقي
والطها من الاحساء على اللقب العربيه
قال الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
بانه سيتم اعتقاله يوم الثلاثاء المقبل
داعيا انصاره عبر منصته
للاحتجاج ونقلت قناه وفوكس نيوز عن مصدر
القضائيه ان مكتب المدعي العام في منعاه
عقد اجتماعا مع سلطات انفاذ القانون قبل
توجيه لائحه اتهام المحتمله لترامب
الاسبوع المقبل تاتي للقضيه على خلفيه
مزاعم حول دفع مايكل كوهن محامي ترامب
مبلغ ماليا لممثله اباحيه قبل انتخابات
عام 2016 مقابل صمت عن تلك العلاقه
المزعومه بينهما
اعلن مؤسس شركه هواوي تكنولوجيا
ان شركته اوجدت بدائل لاكثر من 13 الف
مكون في منتجاتها التي تاثرت بالعقوبات
التجاريه الامريكيه
اوضح بانها هواوي استبدلت خلال السنوات
الثلاثه 13 الف مكون بديل ببدائل صينيه
محليه واعاده تصميم 4000 من لوحات الدوائر
الكهربائيه لمنتجاتها مؤكده ان انتاجها
لوحات الدوائر الكهربائيه لا يزال مست
قفزات التكنولوجيا لا تتوقف فبعدما اتخذت
الاتجاهات الديموغرافيه مسارا مختلفا في
العالم في السنوات الثلاث الماضيه ولد
مشروع تقني في شركه قامت بتجميع فريق من
اربعين شخصا لتصميم روبوتات شبيهه بالبشر
يمشون ويقفزون وقد يتوجهون الى مكان العمل
بدلا عنك قريبا عيون تراقب وتتحرك يدان
وقدمان جسم ليس بغريب عن العين البشريه
لكنهم ليسوا بشرا بل من صنع اياديهم
اشكالهم مختلفه ووظائفهم متعدده روبوتات
شبيهه بالبشر قد تحل مشكله نقص العماله
شركه تعمل على مشروع تقني هدفه تصميم
روبوتات شبيهه بالشكل البشري روحه الذكاء
الاصطناعي النموذج الاولي للروبت سيكون
قادرا على المشي وتسلق السلالم وفتح
الابواب واستخدام الادوات وصناديق الرفع
وربما حتى اعداد العشاء اما في تفاصيل
التنفيذ فالشركه تخطط لانشاء مستودع وهمي
لاختبار نموذجهم الاولي الذي سيكون
كهربائيا بالكامل ويعمل لمده خمس ساعات
لكن عقبات قد تقف في طريق الخبراء اذ ان
الروبوتات الشبيهه بالبشر من الصعب جدا
بناؤها وهندستها لاداء موثوق به
التصميم سيستغرق عقودا حتى تتمكن
الروبوتات من تكرار الاشياء المعقده التي
يمكن لاجسامنا القيام بها لكن الحالمين
يبذلون قصار جهدهم في محاوله لتحقيق ذلك
ختم الرابع
تم خلال مباحثتنا تناول كافه قضايا
العلاقات الثنائيه
والمصريا في القاهره خطوه نحو التطبيع
الكامل واعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
السعوديه تعلن ختاما اكبر تمرين بحري
عسكري 7000 مشارك من 50 دوله ومنظمه
مصادر العربيه تكشف عن مليون تصريح للعمره
في رمضان حتى الان والتوقعات خمسه اضعاف
ثمانيه ايام على بدايه تطبيق النظام
السياحه الجديد في السعوديه ترخيص الزاميه
للانشطه والاستشارات
الخدمه لتوثيق المطاعم التراثيه في
السعوديه انخفاضا على الهويه وطريقه
التقديم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]